طموحه شغوفه مثابره انا اسمي نور حماد
وانا افتخر انا لاجئه فلسطينيه من لبنان
[موسيقى]
قص اليوم رايحه شريكه معكم هي اصلا يمكن
كثير من البنات عشوهم وخصوصا البنات
العاشقين بمجتمعنا انا تخرجت من ايوبي
يعني الجامعه الامريكيه بيروت بيبي
ازبنكريشن بس خلصت قررت انه راح اعمل
مجسات لانه انا بحب الالم بحب الاكاديمي
بحب الشغل بالاكاديميا انا كثير شغوف
بالعالم وفعلا انا قبلت عليها بس هي موقع
انه انا ساكنه هون بلبنان طبعا هون بلش
فعل العالم لانه يعني الانسان بيكون غير
مالوف احيانا عليه الوضع في هالشي طبيعي
فهموني كان الناس يعني
فبلاش اسمع عبارات انا واهلي بالاخص الي
بلشوا يسمعوا عبارات مثل راح تبعثوها على
امريكا لحاله بلا محرم او مثلا
البنت بالاخير محلها بيت جوزها او بالمطبخ
لتسمعتها الجمله انا هون اتلخبطت كثير
مشاعري خفت كثير ليه لانه خفت اهلي يردوا
على هيك عالم بها المجتمع الذكور اللي
عندها الصوره النمطيه التقليديه عن دوري
وظيفه المراه بالمجتمع مثل ان هي محلها
المطبخ وهي صوره خاطئه تماما
الحمد لله انه انا اهلي خريجين جامعات
متعلمين وكل شيء فا هن يعني كانوا داعمين
للفكره لانه عارفين انه انا عندي هذا
الحلم من الطفوله وبدي احققه وهن ربوني
انا واخواتي نحن صغار نحن نكون مثابرين
وسهلين بالمجتمع ونكون كباده تغيير نحو
الافضل
طبعا الحمد لله يعني بفضل الله سبحانه
وتعالى اولا وبعدين بفضل دعم اهله بلاش
اتفوق وتخرجت بتفوق وبلشت تفوق الى التفوق
واخذت منها كامله كمان دراسه العليا
من المستقبل الفلسطيني
سواره عن طريق انه انا بوصل صوت الشعب
الفلسطيني لبره وكمان شيء ثاني هو انا عم
بكون مصدر الهام اتمنى يعني اكون مصدر
الهام لهذا الشاب الفلسطيني والشباب
الفلسطيني لان خصوصا في لبنان احنا من
وجهه كثير من الصعوبات وكثير في عقوبات
الطريقنا حلم ثاني مثلا لما اكون قدره
ايجابيه للنساء بالمجتمعنا الفرجين انه
فعلا البنات تقدر توصل لما يكون في عندها
ظروف المناسبه بالبيئه المناسبه مع الاهل
الداعمين له انه هي فعلا تحارب المستمع
اللي احنا عايشين فيه لان عنده مثل ما ان
الصوره النمطيه التقليديه عن شو احنا
وظيفتنا كان سبب المجتمع وحلم من الناحيه
الثانيه لانه لقيت المستشفى
لانه انا حابه كمان يعني اعمل تغيير من
ناحيه غذائيه على مستوى العالم فانا نحس
مثلا
من طريقه غذائيه
[موسيقى]